se desplegaron equipos de policía
militares y de respuesta de desastres y
el esfuerzo de rescate continúa más de
177 personas han sido rescatadas hasta
el momento dijeron las autoridades
citando negligencia grave y mala gestión
los oficiales de estación de policía de
la ciudad de morby presentaron un
informe sobre el incidente el informe
nombró a la agencia responsable del
mantenimiento del puente y a la agencia
de administración como acusados sin
nombrar a la empresa a cargo del
mantenimiento y reparación ni a personas
específicas dijeron los oficiales una
portavoz del grupo oreda una empresa
privada responsable del mantenimiento Y
la gestión del puente afirmó que el
puente se derrumbó porque demasiadas
personas en la afección media del puente
intentaban jalarlo de un lado a otro son
defengs de la director general del
municipio de morby dijo que la empresa
privada abrió el puente a Los visitantes
sin notificarnos y por lo tanto no
podemos realizar una auditoría de
seguridad del puente el municipio local
no había emitido ningún certificado de
actitud después del trabajo de
renovación el Primer Ministro nerendro
Moody quien se encuentra una gira por
curiosidad por las elecciones visitará
amor vi el martes Expreso mis
condolencias a las familias de quienes
perdieron la vida en la tragedia dijo el
Primer Ministro además el gobierno ha
anunciado una ayuda alrededor de 2.400
dólares por los familiares o los
fallecidos y 600 dólares por los heridos